when you're on american idol and you've
got other great singers like a friend of
mine ellie yamin who i
freaking love yeah he's saying i have an
album and he's saying he's like yeah
i'll come sing on your album i was like
really
that dude's voice is ridiculous he's
like a little michael mcdonald in a way
yeah he's got soul james ingram he's
always on
like his i've never heard that dude off
pitch ever it's just amazing right
yeah we always do that i'll keep going
be karaoke
jammed that um so when you're watching
mcphee and all these people
in the beginning and you're this young
guy what are you 26
26 26 and you're watching these guys on
stage
and you're going out there in front of
millions
i mean biggest show ever are you
[ __ ] your pants or are you just com
filled with confidence uh it was
definitely a bit of both uh
that was a new that was a new thing for
me man i i was so used to being in front
of like
you know 100 people at the most you know
and
and those a lot of them i knew because i
put them on the guest list
you know what i mean um and then i'm out
there with no guitar because you
couldn't play instruments on the season
i was on
i'm used to being with my band and you
know i had
had back up i had and then i'm out there
18 20 feet from the band no instrument
and i have to keep my eyes open and look
at the camera i always close my eyes
when i sing it's like a
it's like a natural reflex i have such
bad atd
if i see anything that distracts me or
someone's talking or trying to get my
attention
lyrics out the door are we brothers i
think we're brothers then because that's
exactly what happens to me
dude i i just can't i can't do it
um and so i i closed my eyes a lot but
i had to like force myself to look at
the camera and find the camera and it
was so awkward for me
were you calling your wife going were
they crazy eyes were they okay were
there sexy eyes
what kind of eyes was that given the the
world i think they were
sexy crazy okay thanks honey you know
yeah yeah i didn't uh i didn't really
think about it much
i as a matter of fact i go back and
there were still times i had my eyes
closed they were always like no you got
to find the camera you got to look at
the audience you got to think about the
people at home on the other side of the
tv i'm like
man i'm just trying to get through this
song yeah
isn't there a part of you that wants
like i mean you probably won't admit it
but
i think i would not to be a dick but i'd
feel better if the person ahead of me
just [ __ ] up a little bit at least
just kind of [ __ ] up please [ __ ] up
then then i'll feel better
you're secretly waiting for it you're
like give me something
give me something yeah you want mcphee
to miss a beat or forget a line or [ __ ]
up
and yeah you want it kind of right
because you want to win
you know it's like and if they're good
and if they did great
everybody up before you and you're the
one that's the first one
you're like man hopefully the next
person [ __ ] up too
yeah or if you're last and you're like
oh my god yeah mean crushed
taylor hicks just crushed with us dude
i mean are you still friends with those
guys i still
keep in touch with elliot i actually ran
into elliott in the airport
um in vegas last year before everybody
just had a baby
you know tits up yeah um
ace lives like 10 minutes for me he's in
nashville now
um i haven't talked to taylor in a while
but i
i keep up every now and then i get a
text from bucky and
you know everybody's doing their own
thing and we always talk about getting
together and
never happens because everybody's got
their own things going
but uh you do you remember the first
time i met you uh
we i felt like we met at like the
beverly center
i think you're right and that would make
sense because i love malls
who doesn't who doesn't love us yeah i
don't i haven't been to one in a while
but wow
um but yeah i i think i met you
in uh nordstrom
or something in the in in the beverly
center underwear that's right
i just had that mental what do we do
we're like oh hey dude what's up
yeah that was basically it like you knew
who i was i knew who you were and
we you know we were both bald probably
we were both bald
i i think you were it was definitely
trimmed down
i don't know if you were fully bald in
between seasons
in between did you have to shave oh yeah
shave me every every morning in fact i
didn't know that i mean i still would
have done it i was broke
but um they would shave my head
with an electric first to get anything
and then straight i had every there
couldn't be a hair on my head my ear
anything for a minute there i thought
they were gonna shave my ass but no they
didn't go that far
i uh i have to shave every other day i
don't know how you did that every day
without like
just ripping your skin apart oh well
some days some days you just see a
little blood trickle down my eye and i'm
like
natalie she because i know i'm scared
and you're right about the ears man
you shave your head all of a sudden you
realize i got hair there
that has to go oh yeah feel that [ __ ]
blow it in the wind and if that light
hits you a certain way that dramatic
lighting you just get one long ear hair
and no hair on your head
it's like oh what the i don't care what
you sound like cause you look like
[ __ ] chris you know what's funny that
you just mentioned shaving your ears
when i was on idol i was i was in the
bathroom
shaving and it was right before i went
out and i
i decided that day that i'm gonna shave
my ears with my razor
and it cut right there and it would not
stop bleed like it was just gushing i
was like what the [ __ ] am i gonna i had
to super glue my ear
to stop the bleeding and like cake
makeup all over are you thinking about
it while you're singing
yes [ __ ] here it's bleeding
this is when i'm pushing i'm like i'm
probably gushing blood right
i know we're just so aware self-aware i
mean
you